Hey welcome to The Daily denne guys
we're doing things a little different
today because it is Hispanic Heritage
Month we're kicking off the celebrations
with celebrity chef and master chef
judge
I don't Sanchez thank you very much
daddy for having me no thank you because
chef I tell you I came here hungry
and it snows damn good absolutely we
talk about Hispanic Heritage Month and
what a source of pride it is for us we
grew up with great food at home that's
right exactly so what better way to
celebrate Hispanic Heritage Month by
parting with cacique and being able to
sort of identify what the new food
trends are in Mexican cooking well I'm
excited because I know that you and I
are biased because we grew up on it but
good as Mexican food all date every day
I love that and I think what's really
exciting the awareness that's being
created in the originality and the
understanding from people that are not
necessarily Hispanic to be able to sort
of embrace the food have this beautiful
love and affection for it and that's
what's exciting me tacos who doesn't
love tacos or who doesn't love a great
barbacoa who doesn't love a great tamale
you can go down the list before we get
started yeah I grew up with two Mexican
grandmothers who couldn't for me I'm
raised on Mexican food I know you did
too is that what your love of cooking
and your passion for food started
absolutely for me I was very blessed to
have a grandmother grew up in a cattle
ranch in northern Mexico in Chihuahua my
mom followed and those fellows in those
footsteps
my actual grammar that we call her mama
she didn't like the idea of a boy it
sounded very old I mean all about the
glamour my wellies you say don't come
over to your comics have to put makeup
on I love that you know how that is so
that idea being blessed with all this
beautiful foundation of great food at
home has really informed my career and
allowed me to kind of continue that
legacy very much how Latinos are we've
got to think about paying homage
absolutely you know may not get to all
of our ancestors and family so yeah big
time all right what are we making today
okay so let me just tell you what we got
going on so the idea of great
ingredients and being able to sort of
identify that next Mexican food trend is
super important for me so what I like to
do is get myself around really talented
young Chefs and have sort of a most a
think tank a little hump that a little
meeting and ask what their thoughts are
on what that next thing is that people
need to be
I'm not that person I'm here to help I'm
here to eat yeah you were great you told
me earlier that you're a great eater
can't you tell
oh absolutely right I love to eat okay
awesome a-all right so one of the things
that I really think is gonna be an
awesome food trend is the idea of bottom
fo wok or barbecue as they say in
translation and being able to kind of
capture that spirit of low and slow
cooking which is usually done outside
with big cuts of meat and trying to
bring that inside and capture that
spirit so that's what we have right here
you said like open barbecue Raizel this
is prepared yes usually you would take
you know something like goat or lamb and
then kind of bury in the ground with
some hot rocks with a nice little bowl
of chili and different kind of spices
and fragrances and let that cook over a
long period of time so we're gonna kind
of capture that and do it in a home
setting so this is what we have here
then we have some beautiful short ribs
so basically these are the ribs of the
steer okay they're boneless we've
seasoned them very aggressively with our
owns adobo which is one of my spice
mixes and then we sear that and then
basically what you do is you put it in a
pot with some Chile ancho okay okay now
what is Chile ancho when it's fresh no
friend no you can't and you cannot do a
Google [ __ ] or no Google alone
okay there's none of that okay how do
you know when it's fresh whoa whoa Chile
ancho is actually a poblano okay Sheila
poblano from the state of Puebla that
has been tried in smoke that's what we
have here some beautiful avocado leaves
so these are the leaves about Mikado
there you can't eat them raw they're use
they have to be cooked it goes into pot
two and a half hours some Chipotle as
well that goes in the pot cook it low
and slow with some stock and then what
you get come down this way feel the
essence feel the love I feel it I feel
so what we have here is the seared with
short ribs they've reduced the size a
little bit they're tender falling off
the bone okay so that's what we has no I
like it okay cool
we've we've strained the sauce that's
what we have here and then to partner
that up we have some beautiful I loved a
yeah Street corn okay
do you love Street I do love Street corn
actually okay we've done only an a lot a
bar at one of my sister's birthday
parties actually that's how popular was
that's how popular was okay cool we did
it up so the idea being here is that we
take some beautiful corn in season and
tempura
we actually shaved it off the cob we
saute with some beautiful onions and
garlic a little bit of scallion and
chili yeah put some beautiful queso
fresco and actually queso fresco is the
number one utilized cheese in Mexico I
told you I grew up on this yeah this is
the stuffing around for how long come on
all day long right so this is gonna be a
beautiful foil and canvas for all these
flavors to kind of play upon I wish it
was smellivision guys cause it smells
amazing
okay so now you're gonna put your chef's
hat are you ready okay cool alright so
you what you I'm gonna do is put a nice
little base of this a locked in okay I
can't believe how popular street corners
god it's like the kale Caesar of two
years ago you know what I mean so what
we're gonna do is we're gonna have a
beautiful sort of foundation of this
crazy cart and then you're gonna place
these right all the way down in the row
okay I can do that cool you're well on
your way chef Ben come on buddy you know
I play the part
dude it's all about I make sure
everything could fit so let's just show
them yeah come on let's go
you know we do have a full production
crew you mouth their mouths are watering
exactly I got you okay cool so now that
we have that so this is all the
reduction liquid or Ben from the meat as
it cooks so what we're gonna do is we're
just gonna place that right on top oh
all right look and check that out and
then what you're gonna do you see is a
little chili those over there those
tunas the green one the green one yeah
those are some father owned chilies okay
so what we're gonna simply do is place
those around so you can do it just do
what your hand baby it's all good I know
that you don't know you know you've
sanitized we're good that's true I did
wash my hand okay so one on top of each
okay look how sheffy that looks have you
ever seen that's like presentation night
all day that I'm gonna eat with our eyes
100% okay cool
this is good alright so now that we have
that I use a little Eastern escape the
party okay cool okay alright so now that
we have their Papa now we're gonna go
into some garnishing okay so you're not
gonna do this in Como to get here you go
put a little bit of Ceylon throw kind of
on top I'm gonna finish it with some 50
best so one of the things that people
always ask me like what's that what is
essentially make it a delicious dish has
to be texture wise texture important why
is it everywhere
it keeps your palate engaged okay makes
you want to have another bite that's why
when you have like a tomato soup that's
pureed it's boring mm-hmm but then you
have a chowder
Oh YUM you have some diced up some corn
it's like yeah so this texture is gonna
come by way of a little bit of the pita
or pumpkin seeds right okay then you're
gonna finish him with some pickled
shallots okay and then I'm gonna do a
little coup de gras some beautiful queso
fresco now this gesso fresco for me it's
it's rich it doesn't have the salt of a
feta per se right but what it does is it
reinforces all the flavor of the course
it's just like the cherry on top of it
exactly papa exactly tell me that does
not look are you did we write together
that's good all right so now what we're
gonna do is we're gonna clean that up
got a clean place so the dish looks
fantastic here I have another beautiful
example of how to utilize some of those
Mexican flavors that might be a little
bit off the road so we have some beet
salad somewhat kiss-off let's go
some little pesto with some cilantro
come on see they don't know that Mexican
Mexican cuisine is more than just chips
and guac it's more than Joe's right it
could be anything it could be refined it
could be stripped out doing this
whatever you want but just really get
great ingredients and let them sing and
it's classic like flavors to mice and
stuff like that well this looks good
okay
are we taking a bite of it absolutely
let's do it you grab that pop on with a
little bit of everything you roll my
sleeves up it's business time I wanna go
for a bite yes sir oh here we go
make sure you do so try to get the sauce
okay
sing your bring me to the next v/s þór
what come on you're invited all day long
baby why were you doing this weekend
another bite I'm kicking here now you're
getting here all right man yo that's so
good
what a way to kick off Hispanic Heritage
Month seriously oh yeah thank you um
somewhere chef Gordon Ramsay is shaking
absolutely he can we can't pull this off
oh no dude and guess what the finale is
coming up next week on Wednesday I got
my boy sad sad Americana from Houston
you know who's gonna be the winner baby
under some spice to MasterChef you know
yeah
of course my brother Willie we'd be
surprised to know about Gordon he's a
big prankster okay so he loves to like
pull pranks he got you yeah he's got me
a couple of course course yeah you know
he takes me over to his house he's
always trying to get me to do some crazy
work out you know he's like mr. iron man
and all this stuff um yeah yeah yeah
okay bro Mexican oh just dip our feet
the pool yeah I love that well thank you
so much for stopping by today
thank you wrong way we're gonna finish
this plate but also gonna share right
everybody who wants
[Laughter]